so like you
you've like you're one of like the top
twitch streamers just like in general
oh well you don't know what it just was
was one of the he's fell off the most on
yeah
i am i do have the world record for the
biggest fall off of all time from 283
thousand subs to zero
no one is close
where's the sunny v2 video
dude i hate sony v2
i hate that guys we're talking about
this yesterday
yeah why because he does like the random
youtube generator and it's like
how this person fell off and then it's
just like always based off like looking
up their social blade and being like you
gone down they are worthless human
rights and it's not substantial yeah and
90 of the time it's just a minecraft
youtuber and yeah i swear that's like 80
of his channel and then occasionally you
get like i think you've released like
the shane dawson one recently yeah yeah
where yeah yeah well he calls it a
downfall but it's like he's making more
than enough videos
like trying to make it dramatic to pull
in views and yeah
i don't know i mean it's clearly working
it's a boring formula it's the sad
reality of like uh because i was a
journalism student when i went to
college
and there's a
whole semester we spend on like just
general trends
and there was this one news station that
did only good positive news stories for
like a month and their ratings plummeted
yeah yeah and then they went right back
to like sensationalist you know highway
chase bank robber murder in your area
because it just gets more views yeah
yeah i mean that's just true with i
think every platform unfortunately
people just love watching train wrecks
yeah they do they do i do this only
there's not that many actual like big
downfalls on youtube it's just people
just fizzling out of people who quit
like yeah if you quit is it a downfall
like i don't like on your own volition
yeah i feel like i'm done you shouldn't
yeah well yeah like i think we mentioned
this as well like epic meal time right
he just he was like yeah she's not
getting views so i'm i'm i'm quitting
it's like that's not a downfall the dude
just quit but like also sometimes like
you they're creators that just just like
[ __ ] burn out they just need like a
break from the platform but like we've
seen enough people like go off do their
own [ __ ] thing and then just come
back in like a different way or a
different like scene like for example
like ray william johnson become relevant
again through like youtube shorts and
tick tock it's just like so weird so
weird yeah considering like how he was
like kind of like for like the longest
time the staple of like the biggest
youtuber who fell off you know he quit
equals three and nobody ever heard of
him and then now he just did his own
thing and now he's come back in a
different platform they do so well yeah
his shorts get millions of views and
it's all like cringy roasts
it's literally he's recycling the
formula of equals three but because of
the meta right now it's just working
again yeah yeah and it's so yeah it's
because yeah because i remember i was
like flicking through tick tock and they
just like randomly showed up i was like
yeah oh [ __ ] i completely forgot about
this guy and he's still in the exact
same oh he's doing react too yeah yeah
so the thing i saw from him he would
find a tick tocker and he would just
roast them oh he does that yeah yeah
yeah yeah he would just sit there and
he'd be like you look like you've never
had sex in your life you virgin head ass
that was the [ __ ] comedy yeah and
then you know they'd be like really mean
though and then he knows ended with a
nah i'm just kidding
i was like you went in on them
that's the magic wand yeah
but i guess you can't have success even
that many yeah i saw i saw a tick tock
where he literally started off being
like check out this video and i'm like
oh my god that the nostalgia wave of
equals three just came back it was
exactly the same formula i think i saw
one that was um it was something about
drake had kind of like blocked off
traffic so you could get out or
something oh yeah yeah this whole thing
was like man doesn't it suck when
celebrities just think they're better
than you guys right like comment
subscribe
like it's like like what is this like
yeah no [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] i i i
don't yeah yeah i mean it's like
pandering to you making you feel like an
idiot yeah i mean it's giving me like
more confidence as a creator because i i
see them and i'm like man if i fall off
next year no problem there's a chance
there's always a chance baby
i would love to see gart in five years
just on tick tock roasting people
there's no enemy watching
i'm just playing just kidding i'm just
playing man it's the future for god
i think that is the future for all of us
though right you either the views either
start trending down until you eventually
like quit because you don't want it to
go so down that you're sad yeah or you
pivot to something that like you are
makes you happier that's totally
separate yeah have you ever ever thought
about like at which point do you throw
in the towel do you you know at which
point do you stop huffing the copium and
you realize okay guys it's it's time
it's time to give it a package it's time
to give up you know yeah yeah it's hard
isn't it because it's like
because if you have enough of a backlog
especially on youtube even if you're not
making like the most amazing views the
backlog can still like kind of save your
ass it'll make money for years yeah
it'll make money from yeah as long as
it's all monetized right so it's like
you know some people say like oh if i
get like 0.1 percent of the views that i
used to get then it's like time to pack
it in but there's people who have been
around you know who have those like mega
hits yeah that are still picking up
views that are just like sticking around
even though they make like three four
thousand views of video yeah because we
were talking about sunny v2 and his
recent shane dawson video he was just
like man shane dawson's views dropped
off by 90 percent he used to make 40
million views per video and now he only
makes four million only four and i was
like damn i wish i was making four
million views per video
meanwhile you close out a full screen
and you see his views are like at two
mil
he's doing better than you that time i
wish i could be irrelevant with four
million
[ __ ] kidding me
i think it was a lot different because
when i started streaming i decided i
would only do it for five years yeah
right uh and i and then i was like after
five years i'll stop and then i'll just
have to find something new why five
years because i thought that was a long
time i mean it is alive yeah that was it
uh and and i'm at four i'm at four in
may
and contractually i have to do a little
over five
god forbid
but it has trended up enough and now i
feel a pressure to keep doing it also
because i have like 15 employees that i
think i'll go a bit longer but i do like
hard capping and like forcing yourself
to either review if this is what you
still want to do or consider other
things to do right what would you do
yeah
wiki feet
that foot just brightened my feet
do you know my rating on wiki feet what
is your rating on wikipedia 5.55 how's
that possible i know it waits out of
five stars though i know
how's that you're like hacking wikipedia
my grippers are that good that i have
shot above five
where are you ranked on the entire
website i'm i'm i'm the goat
the code
but yeah i've never really thought about
it because i guess i'm not there yeah
i'm also i'm a guy who's scared to think
of future so i think very present it's
crazy to think you've only been doing it
for four years though
it's a long time i think you should just
pull up from the subathon right yeah
yeah
no no well i feel like you were you'd
blown up before then and then the
sabbath phone just like like put your
propellers no really i wish
so okay going into the subathon i
averaged 20 000 viewers
yes holy [ __ ] and then the subathon
happened and it's like
you know neon cat theme planes and i'm
and i'm popping off but then it ended
and within 60 days i was back down not
just to 20 000 but to like 15 to 20 000
average i was below what i was before
the subathon and in my mind after it
ended i was like i'm a 30k andy now i
have i have passed i am on to the xqc
territory right uh but that's not how it
went everyone just left because they
were more interested in the timer and i
realized i never really showed what my
content was
i was just a
state on stream while a timer played
that people were watching right right
and so no one actually knew what i did
or cared what i did so what was the
thing that initially blew you up you
think
uh i originally i started to get to like
the thousand views just from like
posting youtube videos yeah that would
and they were doing like well they'd be
like maybe like 100k yeah uh and then it
was pog champs
oh okay
that's what blew you up i went from like
maybe like 5k to like easy like 10 12
even 15k sometimes because i was
i was farming jokes i like would buy
books and i'd make fun of like chess
players and so chess.com would put me on
like their like front screen like it
breaks it'd just be me uh and i just
used to like i remember every day i
would end stream it would be like an lsf
clip and it'd be like this new streamer
is making jokes on chess website
and i was like yes i am yes i am
and then right after pogchamps ended a
moga's hit
and among us was people don't remember
but it was weirdly competitive to try to
get into lobbies yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean toast was talking about that to me
as well the other day where it was kind
of like there was
you there was like a kind of like
circle where you would always try to get
into the lobby but there was only like
nine nine places right it's ten yeah
yeah ten so even if you circle through
people you're never gonna get through
everyone who wants to join your lobby
yeah so it kind of weirdly felt like
became like political in a sense very
yeah yeah and like the biggest lobbyists
were the otv ones and they had like
obviously their group of friends that
they've had so they would always have
ten but people would drop after an hour
two hours and so i remember a lot of the
times would be me and corp's husband it
was before he had really blown up too
and we'd just be like waiting in the
discord and then it'd be like one spot
open and we'd both be like i'm here i'm
here
and then like we'd get in and uh and
eventually like you know you get in
enough times and i think the one thing
that i was good at was being okay with
losing yeah yeah yeah cause a lot of
people are just their egos are so great
yeah they just hate being losers but if
you're a really good loser and it's fun
to laugh at you when you lose then it's
fun for other people to play with you
and beat you yeah yeah yeah um so i was
cool with that it's weird to think like
how much among us just catapulted so
many streamers happened to like cutting
seriously when they say among us my
brain is wrong
but it was really the it was the [ __ ]
it made so many people and it was so
easy too i remember i would watch other
people's streams while streaming and i'd
be at like my peak viewership ever and
i'd be like averaging twenty five
thousand and i just i'd be dead and i
was like well if i talk over it it is
worse content than if i just shut up and
then i watch germa on my other monitor
right so i just do that
wow damn when's the mix when's the next
among us coming because i i feel like
has that was that like the last
massive trends that really just blew up
a lot of streamers or do you think
there's been like something something
else i think what was cool about it is
everyone was in on it but it opened up
everyone collaborating but now they
collaborate with everything right like
there'll be just people being degenerate
in vr chat together or like rust servers
and they're sweatier or fall guys and
they're more casual yeah but it's just
now everyone collaborates with everyone
right right okay where's among us too
man
dude that's what we're waiting for
i'm i'm waiting for vr
yeah yeah that'll be hyped for two weeks
yeah
and then totally fall off some people
start getting sick of it yeah everyone
hates wearing the headset yeah exactly
well sodapop is going to bring us mute
to the vr chat among us and then it's
going to be weird
it's going to get all problematic oh my
god oh my god
that's going to be an interesting time
yeah yeah yeah so like you do a lot of
events now and stuff like that is that
is that something you've always wanted
to like work yourself like work up
towards where you can get this freedom
and just to do a lot of different fun
events like
how how did that idea come about way
where you just wanted to like do
tournaments and do events and do like
mogul money and stuff like that yeah i
think they're always the thing that
i feel like if you're at a a successful
point streaming and you get a [ __ ] ton
of money you should put effort back in
yeah and events always seem to be
successful yeah uh and i mean honestly i
think the goat is germa yeah right he's
like so original i i saw his like he did
the sims like the dollhouse ones
dollhouse yeah [ __ ] insane yeah like
it's insane like his brain comes up with
that and i know he has like a few coming
up that are like he's told me about and
like he did one that i did with him
where he had uh he was in like a room
and he had a clipboard and you had
people dressed like him oh yeah so to
try to replace him yeah and then it was
a reveal that it was a replaced germa
show and it was like uh america's next
top model or whatever one of those game
shows with buzzers and like he's just
has an insane mind for it but i'm not
nearly as original so i think i'm doing
more of like the e-buy route and like
you you probably saw his stream he got
the the viewership record yeah three
million right yeah yeah i thought my
twitch had glitched when i logged on to
twitter yeah i saw that he had more than
all of twitch combined and it's because
like he did an event and i i don't think
he's like nearly as original as creative
as drama but he's doing events to such
like a high level that it's like every
week you tune in and it's like oh he's
doing a mogul money oh he's doing a
boxing event oh he's doing a cooking
show and i think that's the goal is to
get to there right yeah because one
thing that i always respect about that
is
you know it's different being a youtuber
doing an event versus i think doing
being a twitch stream and doing an event
because you know we can like plan big
projects big videos but we can edit that
you know we can pre-film that we can
edit out stuff that doesn't work you
guys are doing it live right which takes
like i'd argue like double the team to
be able to make like 10 times the
planning as well yeah yeah like the
dollhouse thing like i don't i can't
even like imagine how much how many
staff members he needed to run that live
yeah